Hi everyone, welcome back. And in this
video, I'm here to share a really
exciting feature in Figma with you. This
feature is called the Dev Mode MCP
server. Now MCP stands for model context
protocol and it's essentially an open
protocol that begins to standardize how
context is passed from tools like Figma
into LLMs that might be in other tools
like cursor. This is a really
interesting feature, I think, because it
allows us to start something in Figma
and take it out and begin to work with
it elsewhere. Now, for a long time,
we've been able to share images with
LLMs. The problem was that while there
was a lot of visual information there,
the LLM had to make a lot of assumptions
about what we were sharing. The Dev Mode
MCP server really solidifies that
connection between the tools. And so,
the LLM is able to see exactly what
we're doing in Figma, including all of
the structure and layout that we're
applying to the design. There's a lot
here, and honestly, it's a new tool that
I'm beginning to explore myself. So, in
this video, I'd love to share with you
how to enable the MCP server in Figma
and how to connect it in another tool
such as cursor, which is an AI code
editor. So, with that, let's hop in
Figma. Here in Figma, and we have our
website design. Now, there's nothing
special about this design at all, other
than the fact that it has auto layout
and constraints applied to make it
responsive. This allows me to make the
frame a little wider or a little more
narrow, and of course, the content stays
responsive. Now, to get started in
enabling the MCP server on Figma, we'll
head up here to our top Figma menu. When
we tap on this and go down to
preferences, about halfway down, we see
an option to enable the dev mode MCP
server. When I click on this, a message
is shown at the bottom that says that
the server has been enabled. In my case,
on localhost 3845. Now, you don't have
to worry too much about that message.
It's really just to confirm that
everything was set up successfully.
Pretty easy, right? Now, the next step
is to install a tool like Cursor. Cursor
again is an AI code editor here on the
Mac and it's what I use outside of
Figma. If you navigate to
docs.cursor.com/tools,
here we'll see a list of all of the MCP
tools available that we can install.
Here we see the option to add Figma 2
cursor. Once we have cursor installed,
and when we press this, we're almost
ready to go. Now, with cursor open,
we're ready to begin connecting Figma to
Cursor. Now, with cursor open, we're
ready for the next step. I've created a
directory called Figma MCP here on my
Mac. You can name your folder whatever
you would like, but once we tap into it,
now we're ready to begin exploring. Now,
when we open up cursor settings on the
lefth hand side, we'll see an option
here called MCP tools. Here in the
middle, I see Figma, and it looks like
it's currently disabled, at least here
on my account. I'll go ahead and enable
it, and we should see everything
enabled, including the four tools
within. Now, if you don't see this, or
if you're stuck in a loading state, try
quitting both cursor and Figma. This
happened once for me, and doing so
completely fixed the issue. You can also
always click on the edit icon here to
double check that the address that was
shown earlier is correct. And in my
case, this looks good. And believe it or
not, that's it. We've just connected our
Figma Dev Mode MCP server here to
cursor. And we're ready to begin
exploring that design. Now, the first
thing I'll do is I'll navigate back to
Figma, and I want to make sure that the
frame that I'm hoping to bring into
Cursor is selected. That's the only
thing we need to do to allow Cursor to
see what we're focused on is just select
the frame. Now, if I go back in cursor
on the right hand side, we'll enter our
new chat. If you don't see this and
you're on a Mac, just hit commandshift
I. That'll allow you to hide or show
that chat sidebar. Now, I'll paste in a
prompt here that says to take this
selected frame from Figma and turn it
into a static website using both HTML
and Tailwind CSS. I also wrote that the
result should be a single HTML file that
can be opened locally on a browser. I'll
be sure to put this prompt in the module
if you would like to copy it. Now, the
other thing that's really interesting
here is we only had to say take a
selected frame from Figma. We didn't
need to bring in the link or share it in
any additional way with cursor. We
instead just told it to focus on that
selected frame. With that, I'll go ahead
and tap enter. And cursor is off to
work. It's asking to use the MCP tool.
And I'll go ahead and give it access.
And it's continuing on. Now, we can see
cursor working and the model is sharing
with us what it's reasoning and what
it's thinking. It even confirms that it
can see a beautiful photography
portfolio design. right from Figma. And
it's sharing what it's doing next, which
is to convert that to a static HTML
page. All right. And just like that,
cursor's finished. And check this out.
It has created that new index. HTML file
for us. And it confirmed that it was an
exact design match. It includes the
navigation bar, the content section, and
the image grid, all right from that
Figma file. Now, if we open up the file
here, we see our design right in the
browser. Now, we have placeholders for
those images here, which is all fine for
now. But at the top we see our
navigation bar. We see our content
section and believe it or not it's
completely responsive as well. I also
noticed something really cool which was
the button up here at the top in the
navigation bar is functional. Even more
interesting is so do the navigation bar
links next to it. As I hover over about
we can see that that is also a link and
as we hover over order prints that is
also a link that I could work with.
That's pretty awesome right? We took a
design that we were working on in Figma.
We collaborated with Cursor through the
Dev Mode MCP server. And now we have a
static site right in our browser that we
could inspect, view, and push even
further. What's really great about
Cursor as well is we could continue to
push this design forward right within
the tool. If there's anything about this
that feels off or I don't quite like, I
could ask Cursor to iterate on it again.
Now, as cursor is looking at Figma, not
only is it taking the overall design
into consideration, but it's also taking
any layer names, any auto layout
structures, or even any variables into
consideration as it's creating what
we're asking. I just think this whole
thing is really, really interesting, and
it's the first time I've thought to
design something in Figma, but actually
push it a little bit further outside of
the tool. So, that's the dev mode MCP
server. Again, it's a feature I'm still
playing around with and getting used to,
but within a few clicks, we were
successfully able to connect Figma to
another tool like Cursor where we
established that connection. Probably
the coolest part of it all is we just
told Cursor to take this selected frame
and get to work on it. Cursor knew
exactly what we were talking about
because of that MCP server connection.
I'm really excited to push this forward
and to be honest, it's having me begin
thinking about how I use Figma in
relation to other tools. In some cases,
it might be easier to push a design
forward within Figma, but in other
cases, it might be easier to prototype
it and push it forward outside of Figma.
The amazing thing is though that these
tools are now working together, and
that's just not something that was
possible before, especially as we were
using LLMs. All right, everyone. That's
Dev Mode, MCP Server, and Figma. If you
tried this out and explored it, let me
know. I would love to see what you built
and to better understand how it all
worked for you. Also, as you think about
this new tool, I'm curious, how are you
going to be using it in your workflow? I
think a lot of us designers are now
going to begin exploring and thinking
more about that question. It honestly
feels like a whole new world is
beginning to open up more and more
within the prototyping and the building
phase, and I'm personally really looking
forward to seeing how I can push my
designs that I'm creating in Figma
forward with the help of other tools.
All right, thank you for joining this
one. As always, please let me know if
you have any questions at all. I'm
looking forward to seeing you